we're told that a group of three friends
is practicing for the track meet the
group is going to run one half of a mile
total
if they each run the same distance
how far will each person run which
expression could represent the situation
so pause this video and try to figure
this out on your own
all right the way i think about it is
there's some distance that they're going
to try to travel
so in this case it's half of a mile and
they're going to divide that distance
amongst the three friends
and so the distance that each of them
are going to run is the total distance
divided by the number of folks that are
running
so an expression that represents this is
one half the total distance they are
running divided by
the number of people who are going to
split that distance divided by three
and so
that is choice c right over here now it
might have confused you a little because
you're not used to dividing a smaller
number especially a fraction by a larger
number but that's exactly what's going
on over here you're taking the total
distance and it's being split amongst
three friends so the total distance
divided by three friends will tell you
how far each of them has to run
let's do another example
so here
we are actually they're telling us that
there's some problem that can be solved
with one half divided by seven they say
which problem can we solve with one half
divided by seven and then they give us
three different scenarios that we could
try to solve so pause this video and
think of which of these three scenarios
can solve be solved with this expression
all right let's go through each of the
choices
cara ordered seven pizza pizzas for her
birthday party her parents ate one half
of a pizza before the party
how much pizza is left for the party
all right so what's going on here she
started with seven pizzas she starts
with seven her parents ate one half of a
pizza so one half of a pizza is taken
away
and so that would tell you how much is
left
so this is definitely this is the
expression you would solve to figure out
a not this expression up here so i would
rule this out
walt has seven hamsters each hamster
weighs one half of a kilogram what is
the total weight of the hamsters
well to figure out the total weight you
would start with the number of hamsters
and you would multiply that times the
weight of each hamster so that would be
seven times one half so we could rule
that one out so it's likely going to be
c but let's figure this let's make sure
it makes sense
janae has one has one half kilogram of
trail mix
she splits her trail mix evenly between
seven friends
how much trail mix will each friend get
all right she has a total amount one
half of a kilogram and she's going to
divide that total amount she splits her
trail mix evenly between seven friends
so she's going to take this one half and
split it evenly amongst seven friends
to get a certain amount per friend how
much trail mix will each friend get and
that's exactly what that expression up
there is so i am liking this choice